Up until this point,
we've simply been checking if
the error coming back is nil.
But we can actually do more informative
robust checks to handle errors
we may not have considered, and
to give ourselves better debug info.
Let's start by looking at this
function here at the top.
This function, display error,
we've created to print out the errors
that we find, and to re-enable the UI.
So this looks like something
we can use in all of our
other error checks, awesome.
Now let's go back to
the first error we check.
It's this, the error value that gets
returned from our network request.
Previously, we were checking if
this value equals no by using
an if statement.
We're now going to use a guard
statement to use this check,
and we'll do this as well with
the other checks we're making,
in addition to some new
errors we're checking for.
We'll explain guard
statements a little bit, but
if you're completely unfamiliar with
them you should definitely check out
the guard statement swift syntax lesson.
To explain guard statements let's look
at what we're doing with this data
that get's returned.
If you recall from before,
we were using optional binding.
That's the if let's it syntax to get
our data out of optional form and
make sure it exists.
We're actually still checking that but
in a slightly different way.
By using the guard statement we're
actually now only checking if the data
doesn't exist.
And using our display error function
to display an error if that's the case.
If the data does exist,
we get to move on and
the data is no longer an optional form.
This is nice because it's quick and
it allows us to avoid those
large nested if statements.
You can see that down here we have
made the same small adjustment for
photos dictionary and image URL string.
It's a neat, effective alternative
to the if statements we have there
previously.
Now back up here let's put back in
the check to see if error equals nill,
this time using a guard statement.
Now you'll notice with all of these the
guard statement keeps the conditions and
associative errors to
display in one place.
Which ends up making
our code a lot cleaner.
Lastly, let's just add in
a few more error checks,
did we get a successful HTTP response?
This statement checks to make sure our
status code is in the 200s range or
the success range.
Now let's check down here after
we've used NSJSONSerialization
to see what we're saving in parse
result is actually okay and usable.
Great, we're responsibly checking for
errors.
Note that we can actually combine many
of these guard statements together,
but we've separated each into its own
statement to make it more clear what
their purposes are.
If you feel comfortable with what
each of these statements does,
you can feel free to
combine them yourself.